I feel most American when I'm barbecuing
a lot of bacon I feel most American when
I am here in New York City but I go eat
pizza and what you've had to express
every day I feel most American when I'm
outside the US because like for an
example when I go to Mexico and people
call me good Inga it it sinks into me
that oh wait I am from the US what uh me
personally I feel like when I go out of
town being a tourist I feel most
American when I go to other countries
also one time when I went to England
everybody was like I love your accent
and I was like oh yeah I'm American
it's big English without a British
accent
I'm not American one time I felt truly
American was after 9/11
and the tragedy that took place at the
Twin Towers um I felt the most American
on like holidays like 9/11 Labor Day
Memorial Day I feel most American when I
have to defend my nationality I've been
asked to go back to my car I've been
told to go back to my country before and
I think it's kind of ridiculous because
I I've been born I was born in Loretta
in Memphis Tennessee
I've lived in Minnesota I've lived all
across the country and I've I've been to
48 states already I love this country
I've never been anything else but
American and to defend my nationality
makes me feel very American to words